thank you for coming to women surviving
and thriving in games media we're glad
you guys could be here you will notice
there's cards in this main hallway we
have a moderator Christine she's right
there
if you guys have questions while we're
talking we'd love if you wrote them down
and directed them towards Christine
she'll put a symbol on there and give it
back to you and then 15 minutes at
before the end of the show we'll invite
people to come to the podium and ask
those questions at that time so we will
probably get started I think the best
way to start is just to give a brief
background on all of us in case there's
any new faces possibly mine my name is
Mary Kish I've been in games media for
about four years I started at a small
publisher I moved on to starting my own
indie game video and marketing company
where I made trailers for indie games
and then I moved on to GameSpot where I
am now a producer video production video
editor and producer of live show like
the lobby good morning how's everyone
doing all right cool
my name is Neha Tiwari I'm the executive
producer at GameSpot at CBS I games and
I've been in new media for over 10 years
I started out in tech I worked at C net
and I've worked at revision3 I worked at
IGN so I've worked with many of these
lovely people
on the panel here and I've loved gaming
since I was a child my first system was
the NES my favorite game at the time was
Metroid and my favorite moment was
finding out that saying this was a girl
I'm sure a lot of you felt that way too
and you saw those beautiful pixels I'm
very excited to be here and I this is
just a great moment I'm so happy to be
here
hello everyone I'm Naomi Kyle I work for
IGN I'm an on-camera host I'm an actress
and I do production and writing for IGN
I do a show called top five everyday
guys maybe know the daily fix it's just
like three minute long video of all the
gaming news that happened that day and
it's up on our site it's up on YouTube
I'm also happy to be here and my first
game was Donkey Kong Country on the NES
my first console though was the ps1 and
I've loved games ever since yeah cool
happy to be here hi everybody
I'm Jessica Chobot I believe that I'm
actually 10 years in the industry this
year I've hosted over at IGN at g4 and I
currently host at Nerdist news over at
nerdist.com and I have just launched a
podcast called bizarre States over there
so if you like weird spooky stuff please
go check it out um it's very freaky and
kind of so mostly hosting but also I've
dabbled in some game dev and writing
with a game called daylight out by
zombie studios which maybe you'd like to
maybe you did it but needless to say I
wrote it so nice it was a nice chance to
do something on the other side of things
and to kind of understand more of what
actually goes on in the developing and
publishing world that even as a media
person I had absolutely no idea was as
difficult as it was I guess for personal
things my first console was actually an
Atari 2600 although I would always go to
my friend's house to hang out with her
cuz she had an NES and that was really
the only reason why she was my friend so
yeah I'm a bad person and that's kind of
hard to say about me
hi um I am Megan Brooke mesh I work for
polygon where I am a reporter so this is
actually my first job in the industry I
started about two years ago I actually
just celebrated my university at this
month as far as first my first game ever
was Final Fantasy 6 at the time 3 first
Super Nintendo fun fact this is also my
first panel so nervous barfing totally
part of the show totally casual hello
everyone I am Tara long I work at
revision3 I started out in the industry
about four or five years ago at
Destructoid and now at revision3 we were
bought by discovery a couple years ago
so we do pretty much everything we have
rep 3 games which is where you've
probably seen me from but I also host
about 3 or 4 other shows there mostly
relating to science and current events
like Megan I am a little bit of a
nervous public speaker and let's see
what else personal for we're doing first
video game we ever played first console
was NES but I far prefer the Sega
Genesis I still feel like that's the
greatest console ever made first game I
ever played was probably where in the
world is Carmen Sandiego on our old
Macintosh computer
that's awesome
and this is our panel so thank you again
for joining us and hearing from us
we'll probably jump right in so the
first question I have is what was a
moment in the games industry where you
realized you were different because of
your gender and I'm gonna direct this
first question to Megan um so for me I
would say it took a little bit when I
first started I was working back home in
Missouri so I kind of existed in a
bubble pretty much my only connection to
the game industry was the Internet
growing up I've always known a ton of
female gamers I have a ton of female
co-workers so to me I was no different
that all changed when I finally got to
San Francisco and started covering local
events I started to realize that I was
very often the only female in the room
at events that I was the only woman
covering it and that that did make a
difference it's it's not uncommon for
people to see me sit down next to them
and a team scenario and make the joke of
oh we're gonna lose now and the first
time you hear that okay it's a joke
whatever I personally don't think it's
very funny because it's it's really not
very original but whatever the thing is
when you start teared over and over
again you realize that okay this is
something that more than one person
obviously believes and it's there's more
to it than that because I would sit down
with a developer and one of the first
things they would ask me after me
introducing myself saying I'm from
polygon a media outlet they'd be like do
you really play games and again this is
something that you hear happening and
you think that okay maybe once or twice
but this happens all the time and it's
one of those things where I volunteered
no personal information about myself so
obviously these people are taking a look
at me
the same way that you guys are and
they're seeing something that says to
them this woman doesn't seem to belong
and honestly if that if that thought is
popping your head now look at me like
what is that because I don't know and
it's something that I still trying to
figure out I also had a very similar
experience when I started mine kind of
came actually slightly earlier very
similarly I was from Michigan very much
lived in kind of like a little bubble
where my friends who are mostly guys
would treat me equally and so I
ever occurred to me that I wouldn't be
treated that way if I got into like a
broader sense of of the industry I had
snuck into e3 in 2006 which was my first
III ever and that's an awesome story by
the way but for a different time and and
I noticed that I got a lot of attention
because I was one of very few women
there most of the women that were there
were like say in sales or marketing or
girlfriends that were kind of dragged
there by their boyfriends and you know
that's fine
that's not a problem but but when people
discovered that I actually was
interested in the game itself it was
like I was this weird anomaly and hey
honestly that kind of worked in my favor
I'm not gonna lie and say that it didn't
so that part was great because it
actually kind of opened the door for me
and gave me the opportunity to then get
into places where I could potentially
look for work like IGN and G for the
flip side to that however is it also
made me a target and so shortly after I
did start working I would get a lot of
do you actually play video games and not
only was do I think that part of that is
because I was a woman but also part of
it was because I was in media so because
you know you were on camera you're just
there because you're a pretty face and
you have nothing going on in your head
and that is not the case you know yes TV
or on camera work usually is easier to
get into if you are attractive because
it just is that's just the way that
production works and it's just the
nature of the beast but at the same time
it's not the only thing that you have to
have to offer you also have to be smart
you have to be talented and you have to
know what you're talking about and that
was something that I constantly found
myself having to prove lately I feel
like that has changed for me and I think
that part of that is because over the
years I've stuck with it you know I'm
not trying to use this industry as a
launching pad into a bigger better
career I'm here because I love it this
is what I like to do and I think that
that has finally garnered me some
respect that I might not have gotten
before but still it's taken ten years
and I think that that is where the disap
maybe not even disappointment because
I'm not disappointed I'm very lucky and
I'm very happy but it was it may be
harder struggle than it need it to be
something else worth having I think is
that you know it's one thing when people
on the internet challenge you because of
who you are because they don't know you
they don't I don't think they see you as
a person always because they're just
this figure when it's someone working in
our industry who may be as familiar Thor
were your work and knows that you're
probably working your ass off it's
incredibly demoralizing to have them
discount you maybe just because of your
gender it sounds like there's it's often
or at least in our experiences that we
might be one or a few women in the room
and something that we also have to
address is the fact that often we're
speaking to a primarily male audience so
I'd like to address my next question to
Naomi and that's how do you relate to
your audience knowing that it is
primarily male um I'm gonna take more of
a positive side to this I feel like
what's really great about nowadays is
there's the intranet and more the more
we become accustomed to the Internet
we're gonna see that a lot of people a
lot of dividers that used to exist are
kind of gone and I've noticed that just
through people I've talked to a lot of
guys you know I know just as many guys
who like Disney Princesses as I know
girls who like Call of Duty or you know
MOBAs so I feel like it's become more
and more positive direction we've gone
into a positive direction trying to get
people to forget about the whole gender
aspect and just include everybody for
whatever it is they like so I relate to
people just on you know I like what I
like they like what they like and if you
know we find something common that we
both agree on is a good thing and we
love it then that's how I relate to them
you know and it's no longer
oh she's female or male it's more like
oh she likes what I like that's awesome
and social media I feel helps that just
as much as the Internet Internet does
yeah you know I always find as well when
I'm doing my shows I have a few shows on
gamespot where I am just a voice
so there's I'm not actually on camera
I'm doing a voiceover and you'll hear my
voice on a show called new releases
where I talk about the latest games that
are coming out in that week and I found
sometimes that people would say in
you know they would respond and say are
you just a voice are you just reading a
script well I wrote that script and I
played those games or research them
heavily to make sure that I was
understanding everything I was talking
about using my background knowledge of
games that I played one of the ways that
I always used to relate to my audience
and I think an easy bridge to gap is
humor I found that if I put a tiny clip
of Futurama of bender saying something
funny people enjoyed it and then they
weren't really looking at me as a woman
who was reading a script but a person
that you can relate to that has
something to say and it's really easy to
use humor as a way to bridge that gap
and to come to terms on common grounds
that were all people that love games and
want to talk about them yeah we all love
memes I actually also think that this is
changing I mean obviously there is I
find even just when I started back in
2006 that at these events I see more and
more female faces and ranging in age I
think recently there was an article that
just came out that said something like
oh gosh I don't remember 46% of all
gamers are women and they're not even
just like women they're women that are
my age and I am 37 years old thank you
very much you know and I think I'm
killing it honestly and and so that's
great great news and the flipside to
this and it's not to bring it back into
a negative tone because I do think
things are moving in a positive
direction but it seems like every time
we take two steps forward we take one
back and with the recent incidents that
are happening with Anita sarkeesian and
I don't even know if I'm pronouncing
that last name right and I'm sorry if I
didn't but so and Zoe Quinn as well you
know it's it's that's ridiculous that
these women have to leave their house
due to death threats and it's just you
know and listen I think that like I said
everything's moving forward it's just
that we seem to keep hitting these road
bumps it on the way and and I actually
don't understand why because everybody
that I talked to I could I
feel like I could go to anybody in this
room and have like a really nice honest
conversation and they might not agree
with all my points and I might not agree
with all them but we would walk away
from it great
like I don't think there's anybody in
this room that wouldn't be a wonderful
person to talk to and so I don't
understand why why that's different then
when you're I'm on the other side of it
on the Internet aside from the anonymity
but even then thank everybody like I get
some of its youth and just being stupid
like I used to go into chat rooms on AOL
and be like OOP OOP OOP OOP OOP OOP OOP
because I could say poop and I couldn't
say poop in my house and it wasn't in
poop it was the big word but you know
what I'm saying
and you know so I kept that some of its
youth but on the flip side those people
grow up too so is there's this just
constant like is the internet just Mad
Libs full of poop like I don't get it so
you know I think things are going better
and moving in a in a good way but but to
hear about the zoe quinn of it all and
how hard of a time she's having with it
and and also who's the douchey
ex-boyfriend that posted all that's
personal stuff I mean come on guy get
over it that's the problem
so anyway you know it's just it's just a
shame that we're keep running into these
roadblocks and I and I'd like to see
that change thanks Janice there's a lot
of roadblocks that we're gonna be
talking about on this panel and when I'd
really like to address I'll start with
you nee hi our beauty standards and
whether or not you believe they exist in
the games industry and how you deal with
it I absolutely do you think they exist
I started out my career as a host /
producer so that was something that I
encountered early on where you know I
would I would kind of similar to what
what Megan was talking about where you
go to these meetings and they're like oh
you're interviewing me like do you
actually know what you're talking about
or do you know what this is about and
it's like yes I do I actually like went
to a top university like I'm actually
pretty smart and I know what I'm talking
about and I know like I prepped I'm good
like I know what we're doing like don't
worry about it so there was a lot of
that judgment and
at some point in my career I also hosted
a hour-long live show on on justin.tv at
the time and seen all the comments in
real time like where people would just
comment way more on like my hair or what
I was wearing or you know just like my
fashion choices versus what I was saying
was was demoralizing and you know at
some point I realized that I wanted to
be more I wouldn't be part of the
conversation of like how did how did how
is it decided that I should host that or
how is it decided that I should be hired
to do that and that's when I decided
that I wanted to be part of management
and I've worked really hard towards that
and now I am in those rooms where those
conversations are taking place of what
host do we hire why you know and I think
that and I don't want to like say that
like it's it's coming from a malicious
place or that a lot of times that men
even know that they're doing it but it
happens where they don't realize that oh
yeah no let's go with this person
because they're prettier but it's like
no no wait hang out but this person is
actually a lot more skilled I mean I've
been in conversations at places that
I've worked where we were selecting
booth babes and as you can imagine it
was awkward like really awkward cuz
there'd be times where they'd forget I
was there and I'd be like hey so woman
like let's let's like let's let's be
real here and so I'm really glad that I
that I have that opportunity now and you
know like 20% of my team at GameSpot is
women and and that's a number that I'm
really hoping to get up and I don't want
to hire people because they're women
either like in our recent we we had a
position open and in the final round
there were two women and two men and I
was just so excited I was like this is
so awesome I've never had this situation
before where I've had an equal amount of
women and men in the gaming industry
applying for this position and I just
I'm so happy that I could be part of
that decision-making process because I
think that I'm tired of men deciding
what the beauty standards are in this
industry I think we should be deciding
what they are
yeah to to kind of approach that same
question from perhaps a broader
perspective first off I absolutely
absolutely do believe that there are
beauty standards in gaming but I also
don't think that it's limited to just
games I think all forms of media have
that problem I mean anybody who's seen
television shows or watching movies
knows that there's this common trope you
know where it's this this bald sweaty
fat guy who's just a bumbling idiot and
he's got this like beautifully gorgeous
intelligent wife and it's it's those
kinds of tropes that sort of perpetuate
this culture where men can be taken
seriously and have their opinions
validated no matter what they look like
but women on the flip side have to be
both beautiful and intelligent in order
to be taken seriously and to really make
it in the industry and it sucks it
really does suck and I can't pretend
like you know being in the position that
I'm in on YouTube and in sort of a
front-facing position that I haven't
benefited from that at some point or
another but but I definitely think it
exists in all forms of media
perhaps games are just slightly more
egregious about it yeah I'd like to add
to that so when I was in college I did
like my senior thesis on the
representations of women in gaming and I
was looking more at you know like
Princess Peach Lara Croft seeing what
primarily males felt about these
different figures so it seemed that a
lot of them they found like Lara Croft
appealing but not because she kicks ass
but because she's hot you know like it
wasn't about her intelligence it wasn't
about her skill but it was about the way
that she looked and I I also looked at a
lot of like gaming magazines at the time
and saw like how they represented women
and it is that same thing that you see
in media in general which is like the
shrinking woman the the small woman the
cowering woman and that's something that
that we need to change like it it's
something that the games industry needs
to change and then as media that's
something that we can mimic as well like
I don't think it should matter like
you're pretty or not to be on camera
like I think it's an added bonus but you
know I don't I don't like that there's a
double standard where you can be kind of
like an out-of-shape dude and everyone
worships you and then you have to be
like a really pencil-thin like pretty
and intelligent girl for people to
listen to what you're saying
and then they'll still mock you and say
bad things in the comments which sucks
but yeah going along with that kind of
mindset for these next questions I'd
really like to adjust this to Jessica
and that's what's the hardest thing
you've had to go through differently
because you're a woman in this industry
I would say just off the top of my head
that it would be if I did say something
that people didn't agree with or
whatever the case may be anything that
somebody didn't agree with
instead of being attacked for those
points I would usually be attacked by
the because of the way that I looked so
to go further on the fact that you know
you have to be pencil thin and pretty to
be on camera or to know you know be to
be this package
yes that's benefited me but the flipside
to that is then if you are you get
attacked for that anyway now all of a
sudden you're the [ __ ] you're if you
don't respond to your fan fast enough
you're a [ __ ] you know and I mean just
the other day I had some crazy on
Instagram like harassing me constantly I
mean and he was probably slightly just
literally insane because his sentence
weren't even complete sentences but but
it's like you know I
yet again now I have to go through that
and I have to in and I have to think
about things I think a little bit more
carefully than the average person and
part of that just being in a public
position but part of that is also being
a woman and you know it's got to be one
of those things now that guys think you
know I if I'm gonna post a picture of my
child and I'm gonna post it on Instagram
because my parents watch my Instagram
account and that's how they get to check
in on my child like am I gonna have to
worry about some freak telling my
telling me in the comments that they're
gonna come kill my kid which has
happened you know or like personal
attacks where if I have a cold and I
look sick that day on camera but I still
drag
my ass into work instead what I get told
is you look like like crap you know it's
like well thanks I have a fever of 102
but I still read the prompter so go
after yourself you know it's just I
think that's it it's the personal
attacks instead of being just like hey
I'm fine if you attack me but have it
attack me in regards to the points that
I'm trying to make in a conversation or
the news that I'm giving you and let's
let's have it out in regards to that
let's not have it out in regards to the
fact that you know you just decided to
call me a name and so that that's one of
one of the things and to make a long
story short I mean I've ever longer I've
you know I've dealt with it for a long
time so I know kind of how to approach
it and it's weird you start developing
this instinct on which which comments
and which people you can kind of just
ignore which ones you have to be
somewhat legitimately worried about and
who you just put on a watch list it's
it's it's a thing it's this innate
ability you start to develop and you
know I'd like to just be able to get rid
of that because it's stressful it's
stressful to be on guard all the time
because I do have to be on guard because
I do have to interact with our fans on a
daily basis it's not something as simple
as well if you don't like that comment
ignore it because I can't I mean the
whole point of me being on camera and
doing these things is to have social
interaction with the people watching the
show because one it's fun to talk to you
guys into that's how we find out what
kind of content you want to continue to
see and if we did a good job or not and
for the most part everything everybody
is awesome but then you get those really
really scary people and you need to
figure out how am I going to handle this
and you're always having that thought in
the back of your mind okay I agree
there's always an element when you're on
camera that you might be approached
differently I know that sometimes I'm
often on live shows playing games a lot
of those times those are competitive
multiplayer games and it's always in the
back of my head because it's always in
the comments that if I win they'll be
like oh great good if I lose they'll say
it's because I was a girl or that I
probably should get back in the kitchen
or something really aggressive you can
nor those comments but it doesn't mean
that you didn't read them they didn't
think about it for a quick second that
the reason I lost was because I was a
girl and that can be really hard from an
on camera perspective to keep that
strong face sometimes you'll end up
playing a game much more and researching
it much more because you're afraid that
people will think that you don't know
what you're doing because you're a girl
I'm really interested in hearing no has
to say because you're actually an
executive producer from so a different
perspective on on that yeah I mean I'm
get a little personal with this but you
know I was reading recently like the
White House released a paper saying that
women they basically would have to work
three months or like 60 days to to have
equal pay to what their male
counterparts often earn which is tough
and furthermore they found that about
like 40% of women take time off they
interrupt their careers to have children
or to raise a family so I've been like
married for like four years or something
like that and you know it's it's one of
those things where like yeah you know I
think I do want to have a family but
like with though with that data in front
of me like I find it really scary you
know like it's it's something where like
I've worked really hard to get where I
am and knowing that having a kid or
raising a family might affect like my
earning potential or my future
opportunities or any of those things
like I see Nicole nodding her head she
knows I'm talking about she's a kid
girl fight so you know it's something
that I always think about and like
furthermore like I was joking with Mary
about this but I was like gosh when I
have a kid I need to make sure that baby
doesn't drop during e3 because that's
like a really big deal for us and I need
to like make sure that like I'm like no
where I don't want to be like as big as
a house or something going to e3 we're
planning for conception at a very
particular yeah hi yes yes I've actually
popped at Cynthia about this because her
daughter is like Borneo III is I'm like
okay boy that but I mean that's it's
silly but it's like true and it's like
whereas like my husband who you know he
doesn't work in gaming but it's like
that's something that he doesn't that
doesn't like didn't even cross
mind it doesn't even mean anything and
like there was only like 24 percent of
men who reported taking time off for
like family reasons so I mean it's like
almost half of what women do so that's
you know that's that's one of those
things that I've had to like approach
differently I think if I wasn't in this
industry or if I don't know things were
different we lived in the utopian
society where you know it was cool and
there that wasn't the case that would be
great but it's something that I
definitely have to think about
differently because I'm a woman
yes being that I recently had a child I
maybe I'm the exception to the rule
I felt that out of all of the industries
I could potentially work in that the
games industry and I don't know if it's
because the position I have as far as
having more flexible hours or not but
was a more forgiving industry in order
to have a child I worked all the way up
until I was about to pop I mean straight
up I was like writing daylight while I
was in the hospital waiting for my
c-section and and you know and and I was
on camera and pregnant and most of the
and it was amazing because I thought
that would have been a problem and I
think that might be I hate to say it but
I think that might be like a personal
problem within ourselves as women to
automatically expect that people are
gonna give you a hard time and I'd like
to say that that's not probably not
really the case um you know aside from
taking the I I feel like more people
just just understand like this is just
the way that it goes like you know you
have to take time off to have a baby and
I think men deserve time off to raise
their children as well I don't think it
should just be women I mean one my
husband better get his ass up at 3:00
time at three o'clock in the morning to
be that kid because I'm not the one
doing all the work
there's no way to people to make that
child not just me so you're gonna share
the responsibility and you know I have a
job as well that I love why should I
give up
I work to be at home raising the baby
and so you know and I think guys want to
feel that way too they want to know that
they can get up with the kid and feed
him because they should have that
bonding time and they shouldn't feel
stressed about not being able to take
time off of work legally and and be and
be allowed be allowed to to have that
time and I think those things are
changing I don't know if any of you know
about this but California actually has a
law that that allows husbands to take a
specific time off and also be
compensated for the time that they are
taking off and it's not bad money it's
good so they won't tell you about it
make sure you look into it it's
available for you and I think that's
wonderful and so I think that you know
the the the knee-jerk reaction I think
as women is to expect people to expect
you to want to only be a mother and
that's not the case I love being a mom
more so now than I did when I even had
my child because babies kind of suck
toddlers are awesome and they sleep
through the night
and you know so it's one of those things
where where I love being a mom but that
doesn't necessarily mean that I don't
still love being a host and I still
don't love being into video games and I
still don't love doing all these other
things and I love having to contribute
to my household not even not only as a
wife and a mom but also as a breadwinner
and I love the fact that my husband
works as well and we you know it's hard
it's really tough we feel bad like right
now my husband hasn't seen our kid in
like three weeks because he's traveling
I haven't seen my kid in like four days
because I'm traveling and I'm gonna
start crying because it sucks it's hard
but he's fine we have a nanny he loves
her and I know listen I know that
nannies are expensive and daycares super
expensive and some people just can't
pull it off and so hopefully find a
route that works for you but for those
of you that can I don't think you should
shy away or feel bad for having kids and
I think you'd be amazed at how accepting
the Indus
and your audiences for when you have a
child because again to make it longer
story longer all the comments while I
was pregnant was if anybody said
anything about oh Jessica is looking fat
everyone policed that person and said no
dude she's got a person inside of her
and and that would shut it down and then
when I had my baby I had tons of tweets
and Facebook posts congratulation the
kid looks awesome and it's been a really
positive experience and so yes it can be
very difficult and hard and scary but it
can also be very positive and I guess
that was my entire point thanks if my
mother paying you my mother paying you
know I'd like to clarify with the note
cards if you do have a question
Christine Christine is walking around
right now if you want to raise your card
she'll pick it up and give you a symbol
on it that'll help us to kind of
organize them and make sure that we're
not having duplicates things like that
so definitely give it a raise she'll
come around and grab them from you thank
you so much and moving right along I
have a question for Megan do you think
that there are women who give off the
wrong image of how women should be
viewed in the industry oh man this makes
me super angry um I think there's this
really gross pervasive idea not only in
games but just in general that that
woman did this she's wearing this she
said that she's setting back her gender
and I cannot say this latter enough but
that's such [ __ ] [ __ ] right I
mean
I just want to point out when was the
last time you heard anybody say like
look at what that guy is wearing that
t-shirt it's so [ __ ] like that doesn't
happen that's not a thing ever so when
you're grouping every woman together
you're not only discarding her
individuality you're disregarding all of
her good work but it's a really
dangerous thing to get you're creating
this strange like mob of women and
you're creating like it very much an
us-versus-them dynamic and I think
that's not only a huge mistake but it's
just gross we are individuals like even
this table we're not ambassadors for
women we're just women sharing our
experiences up here you need to treat us
as people not just some big anonymous
group angry rants I think this is kind
of a kind of a tricky question to answer
because on the one hand the optimistic
side of me wants to believe that it
shouldn't matter how you dress or how
you present yourself what should matter
is what you have to say and I do think
that's true to an extent but the other
half of me thinks you know video games
are a fun job but there's still a job
and whether you like it or not the way
you present yourself does matter and it
does affect how people view you and it
sucks because I do know a lot of really
intelligent women in this industry who
are just so smart know a ton about games
way more than I do but they present
themselves the way they present
themselves just attracts the worst kind
of people and it sucks because nobody's
actually listening to what they have to
say no matter how valid their points are
and in a lot of ways I feel like that
does send the wrong message
perhaps by subconsciously signaling to
other young women that in order to make
it in the industry or in order to get
noticed in the industry you have to
appeal to the lowest common denominator
which I just think is could not be
further from the truth
thanks I'd like to ask you a follow-up
question which is often in this industry
when there are aggressive comments that
you have to make very difficult
decisions about whether or not to engage
so Terry I'd like to ask is it
worthwhile for people who support
equality or to engage or debate them
with these types of questions or
comments it's a great question I would
like to bring up a photo exhibit a
continue this is uh it's just photo
number one this is a somebody on Twitter
Gabriel Rodarte I don't feel bad about
calling him out cuz he's an a-hole and
I've done it on my Twitter multiple
times so this is a screenshot of his
Twitter he is super into games he tweets
at all of the major public figures in
the gaming industry talking a lot about
games and then these are the kinds of
things he tweets at me could you go to
the second image please yeah this is
just one of many tweets by the way the
first one was do you do anal the second
one was do you do girl-on-girl and the
third one summed it all up and asked me
if I did anal or girl and girl and this
guy knows who I am he knows I'm not a
porn star and yet these are the kinds of
things that he only ever tweets to women
on Twitter and I think this brings up
kind of an interesting point about
sexist internet commenters I feel like
they kind of are divided into two groups
there's the people who are just
blatantly misogynistic very
mean-spirited and then there are people
who are perhaps more implicitly
misogynistic and make dumb sexist jokes
maybe without realizing how offensive
they're being and for the former group I
feel like those kinds of people are so
massagin ism is so or misogyny is so
ingrained in who they are as a person
that I don't feel it's worthwhile to
engage with them because nothing I or
any of us up here could say would be
able to change the kind of person that
they are but on the flip side the people
who who say things that make dumb jokes
maybe don't realize how hurtful they're
being I feel like it is worthwhile to
engage with those people because shaming
really does work sometimes and like I
retweeted that guy's tweet and ton of my
followers called him out on Twitter and
this is something that we do a lot in
our YouTube comments as well especially
for people who just make really dumb
jokes I find that more and more now
there's sort of a group of people who
come I don't want to say to the rescue
because it sounds weird but who will
call those kinds of people out and make
them realize just how idiotic and dumb
they sound and a lot of times their
behavior stops after that I called this
guy out and he hasn't he hasn't really
said anything that awful to me but
actually go to picture three because I I
specifically put a call out on Twitter
asking for questions for this panel
about women surviving and thriving in
games media and this is the question
that he sent back what video game
character could you see yourself
marrying and again it's that kind of
implicit sexism that totally negates any
of the the real change that we're trying
to make here at this very panel and just
completely turns it into some trivial
diatribe about you know like oh my god
you know Solid Snake is so cute and like
who gives a [ __ ] like who gives a [ __ ]
just like send me a real question so
people like him I feel like it is
worthwhile even though he's a terrible
person but but other people who are just
like get back into the kitchen [ __ ]
it's like who who art who even are you
you know like I don't know what to do
with you so I'm just gonna ignore you
like it's just not a lot of times it's
just not worth your while you really
have to pick your battles carefully yeah
I think that's such a great last
statement is that you gotta pick your
battles with this one because it is such
a slippery slope to argue with people
online and one of the biggest problems
with the currently way we communicate is
probably through forums comments or
Twitter 140 characters is a really small
amount to explain why someone has
inherent issues with women and a lot of
times that can't come across and you end
up being put into one of two groups
you're either you know this really
insane social justice warrior who hates
men or you're a misogynist too super
sexist and we forget that there are a
bunch of really good people in between
those those groups and the comments can
be a very difficult way to give your
your statement I find just as well with
Tara is often at least when I started at
GameSpot people didn't really defend me
too much they didn't know me and I had
to be careful with how well I responded
to now you know if if I put up a video
and someone says you don't know what
you're doing somebody in the comments
will defend me they will they will speak
up for me and there is some self
patrolling going on with great people
and I say good on them and if you see
something weird then that's great to
call it out but be wise with the words
that you choose because they do define
you and those tweets as we've seen can
be known to come back and haunt people
so you you pick your battles but in an
end I would say it's it's positive
because I find that that the good nature
in people it does come out and and I'm
often defended by by the comment
sections of GameSpot users I'd like to
move right along we have a few more
questions I'd really like to get to and
we're running out of time but quickly
this is such an interesting question
Naomi how do you deal with those
incessant sexist comments well you guys
have been talking about it quite a bit
and I feel like it's kind of the main
problem we're always dealing with in
this industry is the internet is just
vicious for first not all the time it's
great for many things but I feel like
we've all been talking about comments
and the fact that we're on the Internet
just breeds you know some you know even
young kids sometimes go on the internet
and they'll start talking negatively and
they don't really know that they're what
they're doing but they find it funny or
whatever I Jan's really great at
pointing out that not a number of the
people who do comment these negative
calm
are a small percentage and I do agree
that it's very important to choose your
battles ignore the ones that aren't
worth doing anything like I mean you'll
always get that guy who's I don't know
like you said misogynist or say
something that he doesn't realize is is
wrong and those people you don't really
have to engage but I feel like the ones
who are flat-out mean and could be told
you know hey like what are you what
you're doing is wrong either you retweet
them or however you want to handle it if
it's in YouTube comments ign's really
good at moderating their comments too I
feel like lately we've taken on an
action of either even like hey we heard
your comment like sometimes people on
the internet just want to be heard and
if we tell them hey we heard your
comment no matter how bad it is they'll
often reply back with like something oh
I didn't think you would see that or you
know I'm sorry I didn't mean to do that
and we just have to keep doing that as
much as possible to feed into this like
almost like we're all you know trying to
be heroes for each other and trying to
you know defend each other as much as
possible and what was the final point I
wanted to make just just yeah like as
much as you if you put focus towards it
I feel like more and more bad people
will die out there's always the young
kids which you can't really do anything
about cuz they'll do what they want but
um and just in your own like homes as
well if you can tell your kids or if you
if any of you guys out there have kids
you know just keep an eye out see what
they're doing I know it's really
difficult especially you know kids being
private and whatnot but I think yeah
it's just perpetuate that constant you
know positive feedback and defend the
people that you admire and you know
don't let them suffer through that I
think the Internet is changing gradually
and I'm seeing more and more people
there was an infographic going around
about IGN editors or just editors in
general in industry who were being bad
mouthed for having opinions you know and
we were just calling them out like these
people are cool to follow let's follow
those these people like no they're not
they're just voicing an opinion so let
them do the
and yeah I just think right now I'm just
seeing a lot of positive just people
looking out for each other on the
internet so how I deal with it I just I
ignore them or I will you know call call
them out and I will pick my battles the
same points I mean the way that I handle
it is um I kind of play it by ear you
know like if it's if it's just general
generic talk just general nastiness I
just ignore it I kind of struggle with
it sometimes because I think you know if
somebody took a crap in your living room
you wouldn't just leave it there you
clean it up so do I delete these do I
ban the person you know but then if you
ban them they just make a new account
like how how how do you handle that I
play it by ear I play it with how I feel
the mood that day I've gotten you know I
mean ten years I've gotten really good
at ignoring it and not really caring and
I think that that's probably the biggest
crossroads is learning to just you truly
these people you're never gonna see them
what do you care you know your parents
have always told you don't care about
what other people think don't who cares
like what's gonna happen um the flip
side to that is if somebody makes a
direct threat against you like a harmful
threat or a threat against an area where
you're going to be like you know like a
bomb threat here at PAX not that there
is one I'm just saying if somebody had
you know make sure and immediately go
and file a report with the police your
local police there I've done this many
times they blow me off make the report
so that it's documented you know whether
they tell you yes or no they have to
take the report take pictures of
everything that this person has sent you
so and keep them in a file so that if
you when the when the that's what I'm
looking for investigator does call you
because they do have to follow up you
make a report you have the evidence and
then also there's an FBI hotline number
which I should have looked up so I could
give it to you guys I don't have it but
if you search on the internet it'll pop
up for cyber crimes which also relate to
threats and physical harm because the
police and the FBI can't do anything
unless a direct threat
you for harm is made so the minute that
you get that documented make those
reports contact that FBI hotline number
and they I can promise you they will be
looked at thinks so that way if anything
does happen you have to go to court or
whatever you can follow up and have your
evidence it's taken a little bit of a
dark turn I would like I I we had so
many questions but it looks like we're
running out of time and I would like to
address some questions from the audience
so if you have an X on your card please
feel free to line up at the mic if
that's not your symbol we're gonna try
and get you guys in the next round we're
trying to get through as many as you can
great Lou all right so I had a kind of a
social dynamic uestion here um what are
your thoughts on the online phenomena of
men and women playing as reverse gender
characters based on the perks they might
get from other players based on sex what
I mean by that are female gamers online
for example and maybe world of warcraft
who may play as a male character like
they might play as a male or core
something just for more respect from
people in their guild or from male
characters who may play as a female
character hoping to get gifts from other
players were your thoughts on that I
mean if that's what you want to do
that's what you want to do I'm not gonna
judge I mean you know if you're getting
some epic loot it's probably maybe not
something I should admit but I would you
know what I would never play a male
character to gain respect I'd play a
male character cuz I just wanted to play
that particular male character and I
would play a female character for the
same reason what's really weird and I
don't know if it's just me but I have
never felt invested in characters based
on their gender
I'm just invested in the character cuz
it's the character and even when I was
playing like Mass Effect and I had a
female shepherd while I loved her I
loved her because I'm the one that
created her not
Sara Lee because she was female and I
just happened to choose her as being a
female because I had the option but if
that option wasn't there I wouldn't have
felt left out or weird about it and so
if people that decide to play for perks
or things like that you know I mean
you're trying to win a game essentially
thank you thank you for doing this
number one number two how do you deal
with attacks and baseless criticism from
other females well we all like each
other so I think that it's it can get
catty I've witnessed that myself
with managing people and also just being
in the industry for a while I think I
don't look like male female whatever
like there's gonna be people you just
don't like or that don't like you and as
far as like cattiness goes like don't a
lot of times people will try to like pit
you against another woman
if you google my name they'll like
there's an image that shop that pops up
of me and like Natali del Conte who
worked at C net it's hilarious cuz we're
friends but it's like who do you think's
hotter you know and it's like it's like
totally ridiculous like faceless stupid
people will always try to like put you
against each other or I mean like I'm
sure like you know Joss used to be a
hosted idea and now naomi is and you
know people I remember I worked at IGN
when that happened and I mean people
were awful about it and I think that
being said there's a certain G for
individual yeah called me old
on camera once even though I never even
knew her that being said she can kiss my
ass I think it's important to also
understand like I actually really don't
like words like caddy or snippy which I
think are inherently you know terms that
we use for ladies you never say two
dudes had a catfight right so I think
it's important to understand
if on a personal level if a girl was
having an issue with me at work I go the
high road you always go the high road
you don't attack you don't you don't
fight back and you you treat people the
way that you want to be treated you do
the right thing and those are kind of
like generic comments but the idea is to
not put it into the idea that it is a
catfight because it never was that
doesn't exist so last year uh stevebotts
editor-in-chief of IGN addressed a
header article was titled changing the
Comets an IGN and I'll just briefly read
a couple paragraphs so there's a problem
with IG on a lot of the comments lately
I've been terrible
horrifying it's probably more like it
while most IGN comments are respectful
and productive we we've let the abuse of
comments get to a point where they
dominate our discussions when even just
one hostile comment is enough to ruin an
entire thread we've got to take our job
curators of our site more seriously so
and basically he just goes as changes
the comment section where they decide
the heightened level of moderation and
I'm assuming other gaming sites have
done that as well since say years past
for IGN and other gaming sites has the
moderation of the comment section you
think Lord or heightened since such an
implementation like say that what the
percentage of harassment towards a
percentage of that harassment is towards
the women and is from teen to a 20-plus
audience right um well I think we get
actually monthly updates on how the
moderation is going and we have a lot of
people doing it just freelancers and
people who have volunteered to help and
it's definitely gone down I think if any
website has the power to moderate their
comments and to eradicate the negativity
they should they should definitely do it
and IGN has done it pretty well actually
I've been really surprised the comments
and the kind of culture that we've
established now do you disagree Jeff I
think now IGN has changed and it's
probably a lot
when I was started up until even at even
right up until I left it and Nicole can
also attest to this it was very it was a
constant fight that I was battling with
upper management to have the T OSF
actually implemented there's a section
of IGN called the vest II which is
basically a cesspool and there's no
reason to even have it there because all
of the comments almost lash and say all
but almost all of the comments were were
negative whether they were even against
females or not but it was it was
blatantly usually when it came to the
stuff that was about me was very very
sexist and Agron aggro and you know I
mean that was what 7 years of me
complaining about it and it never and I
was told like that's just the internet
you know so I have a different feeling
about it maybe than Naomi because she's
been able to reap the benefits of them
finally paying attention which is great
and I think that's fantastic that the
attention has finally been paid to it
and I would like to see more sites do
that as well but yeah it shouldn't have
taken that long and that goes for any
company not just IGN thank you bring
back cheap cool crazy I'm a stay-at-home
dad I have twin eight-year-old girls at
least one I was going in a gaming field
somewhere
any of us to help me race them to be
ready when they had to deal with and I
can't stress this word enough the idiots
how can I help them I think you know
it's all about self confidence you just
raise raise your girls to understand and
to believe in themselves as much as they
can I mean I have the benefit of not
having to worry about that to a certain
extent because I have a little boy and
that's a shame you know that I have to
think about that that being said I am
going to monitor the crap out of my
child and if he so much as acts like any
of the comments like the negative
comments that I've seen he
some serious trouble uh so you know I
mean so yeah for both sides I'd say just
you know mana in general monitor your
children and there's ways to do that
where they can still feel like they have
their independence but then you also
know what's going on
you know those ESRB relay Buhl's and
parental controls are made for a reason
and so I do find that when parents
complain about games being violent or
having a bad effect upon their children
you got to just kind of be a parent like
there's a reason why those are there we
have made it available for you
however as as raising girls in the
industry I would just say try and
instill with them the most
self-confidence you can and the support
of the family and know that you love
them and not to take the comments as
seriously as maybe it would it's like
you know when you're in high school you
know you get picked on in high school
you I think I remember my parents
telling me you know this is just high
school you've got your whole life ahead
of you don't feel bad because somebody
doesn't like you or because you weren't
invited to this party and as a kid
it felt so serious at the time because
that was my whole world
in hindsight obviously it's not so I
guess just try to find that balance of
like when they are hurt take it
seriously but keep trying to push to
them that the world is a big open space
and you can you can make your own
pathway and don't have to worry about
other people thank you I hope that was
helpful I hate giving parent advice
because I not um it's not uncommon to
hear like YouTube personalities say they
don't read the comment section and even
people like totalbiscuit just disable
them completely so do you think that
there's really a lot of value in even
having a comment section on the site I
think that I'm I know that when we've so
in my career I've had a lot of crying
hosts come to me and say like and it's
like oh what's wrong and it's like I
read the comment second it's like oh why
did you do that like because it's like
you know it's almost like this like
masochistic thing you know if you want
to feel bad about yourself dive right
into the YouTube comments like that's
there there's no other sure way to get
there so you know I I don't
I don't know if like disabling them is
the right thing I know YouTube has tried
some you know some new things like you
know of course like removing some of the
anonymity and and making you like who
you are you know so that you can comment
which a lot of people hate as well but
you know we comments are a great place
for people to understand and take the
temperature of how people feel about
your content and it's a shame that it's
become such like a horrible place on
YouTube so i usually do steer like host
to just like look at the comments on on
site so i encourage you guys to comment
on site just because it's youtube is
really hard and i don't i don't think
the answer is taking them out I think
it's just trying to find what you can
that's good and trying to just have
blinders on and realize that that's not
the majority like the majority of people
don't comment so no major game companies
have tried to represent women
differently lately at least from what
I've seen anyway are there any examples
of representations of women that you've
been proud of and also conversely are
there any examples that make you angry
proud I'd say Jade Raymond she's the CEO
at Ubisoft Toronto she's awesome and all
these lovely ladies oh
character sorry I misunderstood I can I
can kind of address this a little bit
last year I think when when we were
doing our top five games of the Year
videos one of my games the year was
beyond two souls and in particular I
really liked Jody's character a lot
because it seems like in most video
games they're they're basically one of
two women there's the over sexualized
over empowered woman I don't want to say
over empowered because that sounds weird
but like the Lara Croft type character
right and then there's also just like
the damsel in distress type of character
and one of the reasons I love Jody is
because she doesn't fit into either of
those molds she's literally just in
normal
human girl and they portray they do such
a good job of portraying her as such in
the game you know she has insecurities
like any other girl she has weaknesses
so I think personally she she is one of
the better examples or at least one of
the more realistic portrayal of women in
video games but would you marry her
absolutely thank you I loved my femme
chef and I love my fem shep because it
wasn't that she was a girl or a guy
she was just fem shep like all of her
decisions and all her thought processes
were just what you would think it wasn't
one or the other it was completely
gender neutral it was perfect because I
don't when I I just don't see myself as
being a woman or a girl it just happens
that that's how I came out and so I just
you know you just right for a human
being you don't right for guy or girl
well I would love to continue it sounds
like we are being told to vacate the
room and I'm so sorry he would be happy
to address your questions if anyone
wants to come up to us we'll be hanging
out a little bit and I would like to
take this time again to say thank you so
much for coming and for your support
we're happy to be here and we love what
we do